time for us to begin our final session
and we all know that we are what stands
between you and having a life so we will
try to be brilliant and expeditious and
also give you all time to say your
thoughts and ask your questions I man Oh
Kirsten I'm one of the associate
University librarians for the Yale
library system I don't have an iPhone up
front I don't even have an iphone I
don't have a birthday today but I do
have one qualification that makes me
uniquely poised to moderate this session
and that is that my office is across the
street at Sterling library and I look
over the entrance to the law school
every day so I think that entitles me to
something I frequently argue that future
libraries are not going to be simple
functional extensions of print nor will
they be completely alien
incomprehensible or miraculous entities
I think electronic information and
libraries will be a seed of rich and
often unpredictable potentials even as
we retain some resemblances to the past
we are given a dramatic and powerful
transition to live through life comes
with very few guarantees and we have no
assurances that libraries or librarians
will survive the information revolution
in the forms that we know them now but
if we know who we are and we know who we
believe then a world of opportunities
will give us a chance to achieve great
marbles this is what I believe or in the
words of a country and western song
writer you've got to stand for something
or you'll fall for anything so now to
this session which is inspired at least
to some probably large extent by
Google's math digitizing program and the
fallout from it we're going to hear a
fair amount of discussion around and
pertaining to that settlement so just
what is it well one of the things it is
is 300 pages long
it resembles an wolpert's PowerPoint
elephant of this morning I think it kind
of depends on the day and it certainly
depends on who's having the conversation
in a particular context NYU's law school
professor james grimmelman wrote an
article in the april 2009 issue of the
journal of internet law it's called how
to fix the Google settlement and he
writes his very opening words are the
project will be immensely good for
society a fair one for Google authors
and publishers however Public Interest
demands that the settlement first be
modified there is a piece in this
morning New York's morning's New York
Times which reviews very quickly as a
news article will the good sides and the
bad sides of the settlement and of
course some of the bad sides that are
described by those opposed to the
settlement are that it could tie up a
very important body of information
privatize it and over time perhaps as
Robert Darton from Harvard says make it
totally unaffordable I think those may
be some extreme views but they're
interesting views and they need to be
reckoned with so we have four speakers
this afternoon we are going to do as our
bosses in the isp project have
instructed we will hear from two of them
we will take a break for comments and
questions from the audience and we will
conclude with the remaining two
so our first speaker is going to be
Jeffrey canard who is managing partner
of the Washington DC office of debe
voice do I have that right I practiced
that and plimpton LLP he practices in
areas of intellectual property he serves
as counsel to the publishers and the
publisher subclass in the google book
search litigation and he is going to
talk about his perspectives from that
role our second speaker will be guy
message who is he said skip the
introductions I want the extra 30
seconds for my talk so I will simply
tell you that he is at the Hebrew
University thank you thank you and for
the introduction thanks to Yale Law
School and the ISP for inviting me back
to my alma mater I enjoy coming back but
I've actually never had this vantage
point in this auditorium having always
been somewhere out there I have been
asked to talk about the google book
search settlement from the standpoint of
the authors and the publishers that's
not surprisingly because my firm
represents the five publishers who
brought suit against Google in the fall
of two thousand five and now the
publisher subclass which is
participating in the class action
settlement let me give you a bit of
background but before I do that it won't
surprise you to know that I'm
enthusiastically supportive of the
settlement and that's true of course of
my my clients as Jonathan mentioned the
google book search cases were brought
because google was scanning millions and
millions of books from libraries and
displaying snippets of those books
without permission snippets are short
three or four lines of text displayed in
response to a user's search request and
famously Google argued of course that no
permission
was required for this activity because
this was a fair use under the Copyright
Act and the publishers and the authors
disagreed with that view the libraries
who produced the books for Google to
scan and then received back library
digital copies in return for their
participation in the scanning project
were not us we're not sued by either the
authors or the publishers the authors
and the publishers essentially objected
to the principle that you could copy
first without obtaining the permission
of the copyright owner their view was
that that turned cop basic copyright
principles on its head felt that Google
should have asked for display for
permission before scanning and display
google of course that well that's not
necessary because what we're doing is
perfectly lawful and in addition google
and its supporters pointed out that with
respect to a massive scanning project of
this sort one which many libraries would
have considered as well it's impossible
to get the permission of every single
person who has a copyright in a book
being scanned particularly for books
that are out of print so the legal issue
before the court was whether this
digitization and display of snippets was
or wasn't a fair use and both sides a
thought that they had a strong position
the litigation would have been
protracted in the district court and
then the side that lost presumably would
have taken the matter to the court of
appeals and then ultimately it could
have been taken all the way up to the
Supreme Court if the litigation had been
pursued in this way it would have
resolved only that question of whether
or not digitization and display of
snippets was a fair use that might have
been the granddaddy of all fair use
cases but we don't know because we now
have a settlement the parties
essentially concluded that a better
broader deal could be struck than any
result that could be achieved in
litigation and over many many months
the parties discussed what would be the
shape of that deal and then ultimately
memorialized the settlement in the
document that you're familiar with in
maybe some of you have have read so why
did the authors and the publishers
decide to settle and i'm just going to
tick through essentially the major
reasons first it's a way of allowing
readers in the united states to find and
access whole books not just snippets in
a meaningful way snippets are useful to
some but ultimately might be frustrating
because it's only a very small portion
of the book that you can see and the
settlement particularly is useful for
making out of print books accessible to
readers in the United States the
settlement broadly distinguishes between
out of print books and in print books
the default for out of print books is
that they can be displayed by Google and
made available through various revenue
models unless the rights holders tell
Google not to do so the default for in
print books is that Google can't display
any of the content of the in print books
unless the right shoulder comes forward
and authorizes Google to do so but the
idea is that it breathes new commercial
life into these out of print books many
of which can only be found on the
shelves of some major research libraries
here in the United States further the
settlement allows for an authorization
based scheme through the class action
mechanism the rights holders are
authorizing google to display books to
index books to make internal research
uses of books and essentially to scan
books and that this scheme of
authorization through the class action
mechanism is consistent with the
copyright owners view and it is to be
sure very difficult in any other context
other than a class action to get rights
from this large body of rights holders
particularly of out of print books
further the settlement provides new
revenue models or methods for making
these books available essentially as I
say injecting commercial life into the
books and the
the through there are three business
models the first is that consumers can
purchase access to a book online from
any computer connected to the Internet
in the United States second that there
are institutional subscriptions in which
institutions such as this university can
buy access to the entire corpus of books
and make those books available to
students faculty researchers and others
there's an advertising based model and
then there are other display uses that
Google can make such as preview use that
is to say that anyone can see probably
up to twenty percent of a book for free
based on their search terms and then
there are further business models that
the settlement contemplates but are not
yet approved at this time such as PDF
download and print on demand and so
forth all of these revenue models
contemplate a 6337 split sixty-three
percent to the rights holder and
thirty-seven percent to google that was
considered and is considered to be a
very favorable revenue split from the
content owners standpoint the settlement
also allows users to make certain uses
of books when authorized so for example
books can be annotated and then the
annotations can be shared amongst other
purchasers of a book or amongst people
in a classroom setting people can cut
and paste from these books they can
print out the entirety of the books the
books are not subject to drm the
settlement also contemplates the
establishment of a registry there our
registries today for example the CCC in
the publishing industry but other
industries other content industries have
robust registries ASCAP and BMI were
mentioned earlier today and it was
thought that the registry essentially
established out of the settlement funds
would be a very useful thing for rights
holders authors and publishers to have
and the function of the registry is to
go and find rights holders retain funds
received from google and then ultimately
pay those funds to the rights holders
often overlooked but extremely important
is that the settlement addresses and
finally deals with the vexing problem
who owns the electronic rights in these
books authors or publishers authors view
was if we've not granted the electronic
rights we retain the rights and so
Google has to come to us publishers view
as well it's the publishers book that's
being scanned so the publisher has a
stake in those books as well and the
settlement essentially avoids the
question of having to go to each
contract and look at it on a contract by
contract basis to determine who has the
rights by saying both have rights in the
books except for books that are reverted
where only the author has the rights and
books where that our work for hire where
only the publishers have the right at
any time an author or a publisher can
exclude a use or remove the book from
the database so it gives the content
owner the control that they were seeking
in the ledges in the litigation and
there are other ancillary benefits it
may inculcate create assists in the
notion that you read a book online or at
least you're able to read books online
which would be complementary to reading
in many cases the hard copy of the book
books will be available in libraries
through the public access service a
terminal that will be available to read
this entire corpus of books online the
database will be accessible to anyone in
the United States who has an internet
connection Google agrees to make books
available to the visually impaired I
mean all of these are complimentary to
the digital rights efforts that the
publishers are themselves are making to
essentially make it possible for people
to come to publishers own websites and
get digital copies of books the authors
and publishers of course have some views
on how all of this affects libraries
because libraries that are participating
in this may get back library digital
copies the ldcs that Jonathan Zittrain
referred to this morning and the
libraries were at the table the
libraries were represented by a lawyer
there were there's a significant amount
of interaction with the libraries from
the start to the finish
of the settlement and the settlement
contains a number of provisions that
explain what the libraries can do with
their ldcs there were some choices to be
made it was possible to design a system
in which the libraries uses of the LDC
was left entirely up to fair use but the
settlement in fact reflects a series of
rights and obligations that clearly
state what a library can and can't do
with its LDC and there's quite a lot
they can make replacement copies they
can use snippets and finding tools they
can provide access to the visually
impaired from the LDC they can allow for
so-called non-consumptive research of
the entire LDC researchers can come and
do data mining and the like there are
classroom and research uses that are
permitted for books that aren't
available in the institutional
subscription there's some reference made
to these security standards by Jonathan
Zittrain this morning these were
designed with major libraries in mind
they don't really require universities
to do anything else other than what they
ordinarily do to protect information
that's residing on their servers and so
I won't speak to the public interest by
way of conclusion because I think we
have a whole panel here who will do just
that and we have all of you in the
audience but i think the authors and the
publishers do believe that the
settlement is very much in the public
interest and well and not the least of
which it's providing the opportunity for
readers in the united states to find
access and read millions and millions of
books which they never could do before
so i'll leave it at that other than to
say that we're very supportive of the
settlement quite enthusiastic about it
and we look forward to it getting
approved by the court thank you very
much
okay thank you all this has been really
a fascinating event not much much left
to be said I was asked to say a few
words about the issue of digital
archives in Europe and I will do so and
then maybe go on to some more general
normative arguments so if we look at
Europe the basic thing that we see is
something which is quite different than
the strong commercial privatized
elements that characterize the u.s.
scene with did the prominent example of
Google library and the library
settlement in Europe there is much more
focused on public provision of digitized
cultural preservation and I'll give you
just two examples to begin with one
example relatively my know yet I think
it's important because it provides a
different model would be the digital
images collection of the Victoria and
Albert Museum in London the museum
provides over half a million images
through its website free of charge
including in the format of
high-resolution images for personal and
educational purposes any book with less
than 4,000 hard copies would be regarded
as an educational huge use those users
do not require permission or payment of
royalties the second example which is
much more potential in its scale in
scope is the European a project just
browse your piano tu it's a project of
the European Union it includes a search
platform to a collection of European
digital libraries with paintings books
films and audio materials it's quite a
huge project at least in European terms
27 member states more than 1,000
participating institutions I think
something like more than half a million
items
and the basic structure is that each
institution hosts its own content
separately but then the content is
connected to the European a patel up
till now i think it sounds very exciting
the only problem is that all users are
respected and subordinated to the IP
rights of both originating copyright
owners and divides of the European ax
and project managers now there are two
main differences between us legal regime
and European legal regime that should be
emphasized at this stage first of all
you Europe recognizes its why generous
database white including in databases of
public domain materials in other words
if poster would put up his project in
Europe he would own a database fight in
the whole internet archives the second
point is that at least in some European
countries for example the UK digital
images of public domain materials may
also be protected by an independent
copyright in American terms the legacy
of files does not apply in Newark what
else is worth mentioning about the
European a project well for wanting not
that if not everyone can contribute
materials to the project only certified
public cultural institutions can so this
is not a democratic project the second
point is that the whole project is based
on the establishment of licensing
schemes with whites owners and this
leads me to the following point moving
toward legal policy in their European
Union well if you go over the reform
proposals that the European Commission
is proposing the general approach is not
to come up with new legislative reforms
in the area of copyright but what'll
suffice with structure wall Institute
you know licensing schemes between major
institutions and copyright owners and
then the representatives organizations I
think it's something like what Google
did with the authors and publishers so
when someone tries to compare the u.s.
approached the u.s. direction to the
European direction I think that we can
argue that we come up with something
which is similar to what happened in the
early days of radio and television where
was Europe followed a model of public
provision the US has taken a model which
is mostly commercial and privatized with
Google settlement as adding the main
example but what is still common both to
the US and Europe is the fact that
large-scale projects are all based on
contractual licensing regimes it could
be google it could be the EU but there's
still a concentration around licensing
regimes that practically we place and
block any hope for a legal reforms in
both cases those mega licensing
structure tend to impose significant
barriers of entry to anyone who is not
Google or the European Union so instead
of leading the required reforms in
copyright law what we're witnessing is
some maneuvers by major players that
basically leverage copyright law to the
two to the dominant position now I think
that these directions have some worries
to think upon and here I'm going back to
the media analogy because digital
archives have major social walls which
are quiet parallel to the ones of media
and entities both of them shape our
views ideologies and perceptions and if
we go back to the history of media
regulation
we can come up with some presumption
that a concentrated map of commercial
and even public digital archives would
not be enough to follow the goals of the
democratic culture instead we need
something which is much more of a hybrid
mixed system that comes up with a
mechanism of checks and balances that
encourages different types of
preservation organizations now I must
admit that all true I think all through
the day and especially when people
discuss the google i will project
there's some sense that the element of
comprehensiveness this vision of the
one-stop digital library for all the
books in the world is something which is
very desirable but to some degree heat
has become some sort of a double-edged
sword because we became so fascinated
with this idea that we tend to neglect
other options which may be no less
important for cultural preservation now
the question still remains where do we
go from here so hypothetically the best
place to go would be some copyright
reforms that would come up with
solutions that better enable a more
diversified landscape of cultural
preservation institutions a proposal
such as the compulsory licensing scheme
form for the establishment and the
provision of public access to a digital
collections in Bordeaux interpretation
of the fair use defense just something
like Jonathan spoke about in the
previous panel I think that Frank maybe
will mention something about a new
version of the deposit requirement that
deals with digital copies so I won't
speak about it but as a practical matter
I think that there are very small
chances that such directions will be
taken either in the US or in Europe
if you go back to the European Union
there is a recent green paper that deals
with new proposed exemptions and
limitations to the European copyright
directive but eventually if you read
this green paper quite carefully you
find out find out that at the end of the
day the approach of the European
Commission is to go to a contractual pet
regulate orphan works regulate
exemptions and limitation to
preservation only to those institutional
agreements with copyright owners another
option which I think should be raised
and dealt with and I think that the ISP
here at Yale has been doing some witches
research in this direction is to think
about new directions to incorporate free
speech t away into the evaluation of the
settlement agreement for example and my
basic proposal in this direction is that
we need to think of free speech not only
through the contemporary prism but also
to an internet generational perspective
in other words free speech
considerations should come up as a main
consideration in a digital preservation
debates a while thinking about the
rights of future generation to be
exposed to a diverse range of opinions
and materials from the past as well as
the free speech white of contemporary
speakers to have the imprint on the
landscape of history for future
generations i think i'll stop here thank
um this is your chance to start asking
questions and I see somebody coming
forward this is for Jeff but if other
people want to offer an opinion on it I
wonder if you can offer any comparison
between the google book search case and
the Kindle text-to-speech feature that
that amazon has now I guess offered an
opt-out to two people who want that
future to be disabled for their
particular book but of course an opt-out
was not sufficient to mollify the
authors and publishers in the in the
Google case and I wonder what you think
sort of the relative strength of the
claim that that's an infringing activity
is well I can't speak really too much to
the Kindle situation really at all and i
think one difference is that i guess
kindle is distributing books with the
permission of copyright owners
publishers and ultimately authors and in
the case of the google book search
project there are millions of books
being copied and there's no privity or
contractual relationship between the
copyright owner and and and google
kindle is in a product and so presumably
kindle would have made some arguments
with respect to the capabilities of that
feature and whether it was capable of
commercially significant non-infringing
uses in defending itself it had it
had it been sued that issue might have
been raised in the in the google book
search case but the principal issue was
a core question of whether or not
scanning and display was a fair use
there could have been some fair use
issues raised in the context of the
Kindle text-to-speech feature but i
think is jonathan pointed out fair use
is highly fact specific and so it's
quite different i think that say that
one was a fair use and the other might
not be it's it's hard really to I think
brought too many meaningful comparisons
this questions also for firm sir canard
I was wondering in the settlement
provisions as they currently stand
there's a most favored nation clause
that doesn't allow any other potential
entrance into this digitization market
to get bet more favorable terms in
google i'm wondering first how do you
think that may affect the ability of
others to compete in this book
digitization market and second to what
extent do the publishers and you as a
representative of the publishers
contemplate further entrance into this
market or did you kind of see it as
something that would primarily be
dominated by google from the outset in
terms of this mass digitization both
excellent questions maybe i can start
with the second question first I think
we've always contemplated that the
licenses here are non exclusive they're
not exclusive in the sense that a right
shoulder can withdraw from the
settlement at the opt-out stage a rights
holder can also turn off the uses of its
books rights holders not precluded from
doing separate deals with its books with
any other licensee technology company a
library or what have you similarly the
registry and the settlement agreement
makes this clear is not precluded from
doing deals with anyone else although
the somewhat challenging question is how
the registry would get the rights from
non claiming rights holders in order to
license a comparable service to a
competitor of Google that takes me
though to the first question and the mfn
provision which i think is not fully
understood by by many the mfn provision
only applies if the registry or a
similar entity can find a way of
licensing a another party rights from a
substantial portion of the rights
holders who have not come forward and
claimed with the registry in other words
let's say there are 20 million rights
holders in the world and a million come
forward and claim that leaves 19 million
left Google under this settlement has
the rights from all 20 million the mfn
provision only applies if the registry
is licensing a substantial portion of
the rights of those 19 million other
rights holders to a third party and
that's a very difficult scenario to
imagine absent really another class
action lawsuit or something comparable
to what's happened here otherwise the
mfn provision does not apply I have a
question for Jeff and any of the rest of
you who want to take a shot at it we
heard from others earlier such as Kenny
Cruz that copyright and communication
scholarly communications are
increasingly global and international
how far away are we from having this
kind of access outside of the United
States because that's all we're talking
about at this point in the settlement
what would it take to you know to get
access if you're in other countries I
let other its answer it but the
settlement only deals with us copyright
interests only the rights of copyright
owners in the United States Google under
the settlement is only
authorized to make uses including
display uses of the books in the United
States but it is not prohibited from
making uses outside the United States so
if Google wishes to scan books outside
the United States display books outside
of the United States google in our view
has to get permission to do that Google
may believe that it has rights under
foreign equivalents of fair use to
display snippets but fundamentally this
settlement only deals with the four
corners of the United States and I think
it's would be up to google to try to
figure out how to bring about a
analogous result elsewhere